so what's my favorite dance move
just like the the ones are kind of like
do this thing with my fingers like it's
the 20s and then the 1920s with flat for
girls my favorite song to sing in the
car
he's a face I saw the sign and I also
really love to sing the Spice Girls when
no one's looking my favourite animal
sound I would have to say it the little
snort that my little Frenchie Bulldog
aysia makes she was and it's so cute and
I just love it so much and I just left a
cuddler when she makes that noise Super
Bowl performance I really love Michael
Jackson's of course I'm gonna do my own
type of show realizing that it's a big
opportunity it's gotta be great I
actually have a Disney toothbrush I know
you probably think I'm joking but I
really do it's pink and it's electronic
and it has four different princesses on
it it's the best part of my day and also
the look in everyone's face when I whip
out the princess toothbrush if I don't
want a fashion accessory for the rest of
my life you know I know it sounds silly
but I think it would be my mom's wedding
dress because it would be comfortable
but I would also have the memory of my
mom in it which would be great gosh the
first time I heard my song on the radio
I was in Canada I was just about to go
onstage for a radio show and my tour
manager started yelling it's on it's on
it's on and man I just cried and I
couldn't believe it was like I was
really proud of all the hard work that I
had done and I was thinking that's right
I worked hard and there it is and when
you work hard things pay off and then I
just went right on stage
my show